un proyectil viaja a 0.07 kilómetros por
segundo durante nueve segundos esa
distancia puede calcularse usando la
fórmula a distancia igual a rapidez por
tiempo cual será la unidad de distancia
más razonable a milímetros vez
centímetros 100 metros pensemos un poco
en esto podemos decir que la distancia
será igual a rapidez y aquí escribieron
la rapidez en una forma extraña la
escribiremos igual por el momento 0.07
kilómetros por segundo por el tiempo
nueve segundos que nos da esto como
hemos visto anteriormente podemos
multiplicar la parte numérica punto 07
por 99 por 163 pero es 0.07 así que 7
entre 100 por lo que será 63 entre siero
osea 0.63 y nuestras unidades como van a
ser bueno tenemos segundos aquí y
segundos acá y aunque no estamos
dividiendo segundos entre segundos
cuando hacemos análisis dimensional
podemos visualizar las unidades como
variables algebraicas por lo que estas
unidades de segundos podemos cancelar
las como lo harían
con las variables aunque éstas
obviamente no son variables
tradicionales estas son unidades pero
podemos superarlas de manera similar que
nos queda pues kilómetros 0 puntos 63
kilómetros ahora esto es razonable bueno
podríamos decir que sí aunque yo no
diría que esa es la mejor manera de
expresar lo ya que estamos viendo
esencialmente una fracción de un
kilómetro yo preferiría expresar lo en
una unidad más pequeña que a un
kilómetro por ejemplo metros de hecho
todas las opciones que tenemos aquí en
el problema son menores son kilómetros
pero pensemos en cómo quedaría en
términos de estas opciones que nos dan
comentamos estos metros queremos
deshacernos de los kilómetros así que
pongamos kilómetros en el denominador y
metros en el numerador cuántos metros
hay en un kilómetro
pues mil mil metros en un kilómetro
cancelamos kilómetros y nos queda 0.63
por mil dividido entre 1 pueden hacer
igual a 630 metros en esta parte siempre
hay que preguntarse acaso esto tiene
sentido porque a veces uno se pregunta y
dudas y multiplica o divide y bueno
y esperamos que el análisis dimensional
nos ayude también a clarificar esto pero
si tenemos algo en kilómetros y lo vamos
a transformar en metros entonces la
cantidad aumentará mil veces para quedar
en metros como vemos aquí lo cual parece
una forma razonable de expresar la
distancia pero ahora pensemos en cómo
expresar esto en centímetros sólo para
mostrarles qué tan ridículo queda si
queremos expresar 630 metros en
centímetros nuevamente queremos cancelar
los metros por lo que tendremos que
multiplicar algo que tenga metros en el
denominador y ahora queremos centímetros
en el numerador cuántos centímetros hay
en un metro pues 100 100 centímetros hay
en un metro los metros se cancelen 600
30% será 630 más 20 centímetros y ahora
tenemos números que son difíciles de
visualizar definitivamente prefiero
desplazar la distancia en metros y no en
centímetros y mucho menos en milímetros
tenemos 10 milímetros por centímetro así
que tendríamos 630 mil milímetros que
definitivamente sería muy extraño así
que nos quedamos con la opción c de
metros